clark county school district has been
plagued with problems recently their
school board infighting the back and
forth with superintendent jarrah's job
not to mention a teacher shortage that's
right and it's really impacting
education here in the valley in a big
way bianca holman shares how ccsd is now
stacking up against other metro areas
bianca
good morning so this is a 27 page report
by the fordham institute it ranks metro
areas for school quality and las vegas
we rank 49 out of 50. so this is what
the report measures it takes a look at
the following areas overall academic
growth gains for disadvantaged students
improvement in achievement in recent
years and high school graduation rates
we spoke with the nevada pta president
rebecca garcia about the rankings she
says many of the issues like overcrowded
classrooms the need for more teachers
and proper distribution of funding are
issues that the district has had for
years and the quality of the district
education system is something that
eventually impacts everyone even if you
don't have a child in the school system
so we all should care unfortunately much
of the quality of schools in the clark
county school district is zip code
dependent
so the
quality of the neighborhood that you
live in often unfortunately dictates the
quality of an education your kids get
which should never be the case for
children who have no say in any of that
and so i think that's really the
struggle
so we reached out to the district about
this current report from the fordham
institute and this is a statement that
they shared focusing on the issues
influencing student outcomes and
impacting their ability to actualize
their full potential was the impetus for
creating the superintendent's student
equity and access commission while we
see the achievement gaps among different
student groups exist these gaps exist
throughout the nation and must be
addressed the district remains committed
to preparing students for college career
and real life giving families access to
effective education options and of
course despite these rankings from this
report there are some bright spots here
in the district so coming up in the next
half hour we're going to talk about
those bianca holmen live local now